this is a production of cornell
university
i want to start off with a familiar
slide for everybody and that's the world
population growth from 1700 to 2100
its projections and its
growth rate and the main
this this population has and will
continue to play stress on agriculture
and the main point of this slide is that
to feed this population increase we're
going to need to
make agriculture more productive but
also more sustainable
as a as a major aspect of sustainability
we need to keep in mind that humans
already control
the majority of nitrogen and phosphorus
flows in the world
and so any any solution to
sustainability which is going to feed
right back into productivity
those those two uh those two goals are
not
uh exclusive are going to have to
any solution to sustainability is going
to have to focus
and to address nutrient management and
reuse
so how then can we use genetics to work
towards this
and really
going into us we think we can use
genetics
to change nutrient flow and so we can
move
from ghost focusing specifically back on
the mace
we can usually next to to change
nutrient flow and so we can go from
this conventional system where we're
taking our nitrogen phosphorus we're
fixing it from the air or mining it from
the lithosphere we're throwing it onto
the
onto our agricultural fields it's
absorbed by the plant
some of it's lost it's used for
photosynthesized
photosynthesis and then at the end of
the season it's
most of this nitrogen and phosphorus is
loaded into the kernels we come through
with our combines
we harvest it and then the nitrogen in
the form of protein and the phosphorus
and the starch and the grain are all
forwarded onto an end use
if we can if we look at this can we we
can use genetics to change
this nutrient flow and fundamentally
change what we're pulling off the field
and as part of that we need to view
we need to view our agricultural
production fields in
a lot of cases especially for industrial
ag as a place to farm
carbon and those nutrients as something
that we need to return to the soil each
year
and not really the goal of production
and so
can we then envision a system that looks
like this
where at the end of the season instead
of the nitrogen and phosphorus being
loaded into the kernels
we're harvesting the starch alone the
nitrogen phosphorus is trapped
within the calm we then take that
nitrogen and phosphorus we store it plot
or process it we reapply it and then it
becomes the primary fertilizer source
for
the next year's crop now no system's
going to be 100
efficient and so there would need to be
um for sure there would be supplemental
fertilizer that comes in each year
but if we could recycle 40 or 50 percent
of the nitrogen and phosphorus
that uh that are needed to keep the mace
field productive that would be a huge
decrease in the amount
that we need to fix from the atmosphere
or mine from the
lithosphere hopefully make mace
production
more sustainable and uh a contributor
a a helper towards mitigating climate
change instead of something that
contributes to it
and so when we're reimagining this and
using genetics to change
this nutrient flow there's two aspects
that need to be addressed
the first would be the end uses can we
get away with
leaving the nitrogen and phosphorus out
of
the maize end uses and then the second
would be
can we use genetics to actually do this
is the physiology in the genetics can we
can we make this happen and store
nutrients within the cob
during kernel loading and so
i want to talk about the end uses first
and if we look at may's end uses if we
take the 2019
maze harvest which is about 340 million
metric tons
of maize 40 of that goes into ethanol
production
and 40 goes directly
out of ethanol production the starch is
used is converted to sugar
and then into ethanol any component
that's not starch
comes out and this is is called stillers
grains or solubles
and those distillers grains are mostly
used
for animal feed and so we end up with
80 percent of the phosphorus and 80
percent of the protein
in may's grain being used
in animal feed so that ends up being
about a million metric tons of
phosphorus
about 30 million metric tons of protein
and so we need to address whether
in lifestyle feed we can eliminate these
two components
i would argue that for phosphorus we can
already
for sure we can we can decrease or even
eliminate it
in the base kernel with minimal effect
on
on in animal feeds and the reason that
it there's two reasons for that
one is that maize primarily stores
phosphorus as
phytic acid which is not digestible in
mono room and animals
this could be somewhat mitigated by the
addition of
phytase either by modifying
modifying genetically modifying these
animals to endogenous endogenously
produced phytase or by adding it to the
feed ration
but that doesn't address the second
issue
which is purely the amount of
phosphorus that these animals are being
fed
it's too much for them to use
effectively and absorb effectively and
so we end up with a large pool of
excreted phosphorus
and there's difficulty concentrating
that enough to make
movement of it to uh
to it's difficult to concentrate that
excreted phosphorus into a form that's
economically viable to move the
distances that's needed
um maize nitrogen so mace protein
is is more unclear the end use of this
definitely needs to be investigated more
so the digestibility and end use
is higher than in phosphorus
and protein is also used as
metabolizable energy
by these animals but that has to be
balanced with the fact that
half of the maize nitrogen is being
funneled through
ethanol production and the drying of
distillers grains represents a large
energy sink in an ethanol plant
and so this
on to the next point here projections on
the future of animal production
so y'all have probably all heard ed's
talk about where we're going to get
protein in the future and if that
happens
that's going to serve to decrease the
value of maize protein
freeing up freeing up
nitrogen for recycling on field
so one of the things that i would like
to do this year and i will be doing this
year is some engineering modeling and
economic modeling
to help us answer this question of where
of whether nitrogen
and when nitrogen will become available
for reuse
so moving on to physiology physiology
and the genetics real quick
i just want to point out that maize is
really well positioned to allow for two
product streams
kernels and cobs they're manageable size
and mass
and i also want to point out that the
mace cobb is mostly vascular
and structural tissue and
this storage of nutrients and vascular
and structural tissues is not new and so
the physiology of storing
nitrogen and phosphorus within the maize
cod is not something that's incredibly
outlandish this is
these are bark storage proteins and
populous and so
in the winter we can see that there's a
lot of protein storage vacuoles
and then in the summer those all
disappear because they've been removed
all that protein has been re-mobilized
for leaves for photosynthesis
focusing even with an even
with an even uh
even closer closer up image of these
protein storage vacuoles
we see that phosphorus is stored
in a very similar manner in these
perennial species as it is in
the maze kernel and so this begs the
question of
are protein storage and phosphorus
storage really evolutionarily
conserved and is it just the location of
the deposition
nitrogen and phosphorus would be
deposited in seeds whereas in perennials
it's stored in permeating tissues so
that it can be used year after year and
so
that makes the question is it
evolutionary con
evolutionarily conservative and can we
use that
to uh to develop a uh
a maze a maze plant that stores
nutrients in the cavity of the season
and so with that in mind the question
then becomes can we turn mace cops into
nutrient sieves such that at the end of
the season
that's intercepting and storing nitrogen
phosphorus
in the cob and preventing its loading
into the cross and
so as a concept it seems like this idea
would work
so focus further uh
further research and experiments would
need to be performed on this
so that's what we're hoping to look into
in the coming year and so this also begs
the question
does may store any nutrients in the cob
currently
at the end of the season the short
answer to that is is
no maize does not have any natural
variation for cod nitrogen at the end of
the season
and we would expect the same to be true
for phosphorus
and that's simply because it's an annual
plant there's no benefit to it
for mace to store any nutrients
because it won't be able to access those
easily in the next year
um it benefits to shunt all the
nutrients that it can
into the kernel and so
the accumulation of nitrogen and
phosphorus in the cob is going to
represent a challenge to genetic
modification
um it's going to require a lot of
research to implement
so appropriate modifications must be
identified and perennials can perhaps
serve as a source of inspiration
and genetics and so as we've seen with
the popular species
there is lots of uh there
there is storage of nutrients in
vascular system that we perhaps can
leverage
for
for the for the for the development of a
system
like this and so but perennials but
more closely related species may be
better better sources and so one of the
things that we're hoping to
do is we have tryptophan available in
the cornell fields
we're going to see what nitrogen storage
proteins
does trypsicum use
within its rhizomes to store nitrogen in
successive years and so
we'll do proteomic analysis in the in
the summer and the winter and look for
changes in relative abundance
and maybe we'll segment segment it out
and see if we can't find
where it's storing where it's storing
its nitrogen and
as part of that we can use these
the sequences of these proteins to
perhaps identify homologs and maize that
could be co-opted
or use those actual proteins
as sources for modification
so with that coming up on time i want to
acknowledge usda in the buckler lab and
i would love to have
your questions here
awesome thank you for that great talk
travis if anybody has a
question or two we have maybe a minute
some from mike gore could turning the
cobs into a nutrient sieve
work through alternating alternate
altering tissue specific regulation of
native maize genes
or would it require a transgenic gene
insertion approach so i
i do not know i would imagine that
something that i would imagine that it
might be possible
by alternating tissue-specific
regulation of native maize genes
but it might be easier to do using a
transgenic approach but i do not know
um one of the experiments that we would
love to do if we uh
if we can partner with some
with with any of these flight leading
companies
would be to express opaque two in the
cob and see what happens
so from kevin how many sessions of trips
to come
do you intend to look at and assess
natural variation for in storage and
horizons
we have
we're looking at it in about 10 sessions
and that's a pretty wide range we've got
fluorodonum and
the dactyloides and some of their
crosses as well
any uh anymore any more questions
feedback
and if we don't have time to ask a
question or to formulate
formulate a question please send me an
email i'd love to have feedback
push back on this idea um so
travis just real quick uh assuming you
you have all this p
and n in the cob do you just leave the
cobs in the field or you have to
harvest them and take them somewhere or
what do you do that would be a that
would be another aspect that would need
to be
need to be examined so there's
when you grow soybeans or when one grows
soybeans
the next year there's typically a yield
bump in maize
and the thought behind that is that the
uh the nitrogen and the root nodules
from the previous soybean crop
contributes to the available nitrogen
for the maize plant and uh increases the
soil
for that crop and so well
root nodules are pretty magnified tissue
just like a mace
cob there's differences for sure
but it might be that if we deposit the
nutrients within the cob the cob is a
lignified tissue that would
degrade slowly and provide sort of a
slow release fertilizer
for the maize crop but that would
require
more research and simply testing that
out
and it may be the case that the cobs
need to be harvested
and stored stored over winter and then
chemically processed in some manner to
make that
uh make the nnp available
hopefully that answers your question
there
awesome thank you again for that that
great talk travis and the great
discussion
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu